de la proposition de résolution visant à
appeler la France et l'Union européenne
inscrire le groupe militaire privé
Wagner sur la liste des organisations
terroristes
nous commençons par la discussion
générale avec Monsieur Benjamin Haddad
du groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur l'Ambassadeur
d'Ukraine chers collègues nous sommes
aujourd'hui le 9 mai jour de l'Europe et
pour la deuxième année consécutive une
journée endeuillée par la guerre
d'agression que mène la Russie contre
l'Ukraine sur notre continent depuis
plus d'un an les Ukrainiens résistent de
façon héroïque à l'invasion et la France
avec ses alliés européens soutiennent
l'Ukraine par les sanctions les
livraisons d'armes et la diplomatie aux
côtés de la Russie Poutine une armée du
chaos soutient les régimes despotique en
Afrique et au Moyen-Orient au Soudan en
Libye en Syrie au service du régime de
Bachar al-Assad dans la guerre
d'agression contre l'Ukraine au Sahel ou
les intérêts de la France ont été
directement visées par des opérations
des informations partout il s'implante
les membres du groupe Wagner s’aime
l'instabilité et la violence amour à
barmut à bosangoa abucha à Bria ils
assassinent les tortures il massacre et
pille ils intimides et manipulent dans
un impunité quasi totale
le rôle de Wagner dans ses exactions
nombreuses a été révélée par des ONG des
journalistes dont certains que je salue
aujourd'hui dans cette salle c'est grâce
à leur travail d'investigation joue
courageux et déterminer que l'on peut
aujourd'hui avoir ce débat non les
membres du groupe Wagner ne sont pas des
simples mercenaires attirés par la pas
du gain il poursuivent une stratégie
globale du Mali à l'Ukraine de soutien à
la politique d'agression du régime de
Poutine contre nos démocraties ils sont
un instrument de guerre hybride
l'ennemi nous a désigné nous n'avons pas
choisi mais nous devons l'assumer ils
s'attaque à nos intérêts à nos valeurs à
nos systèmes de gouvernement partout il
le peut il s'ingère dans nos processus
démocratiques comme aux États-Unis en
2016 ou en France en 2017 avec les
usines à troll de prix gozzine ils
montent des faux charniers pour faire
accuser la France comme à Gossi l'an
dernier et amplifie la propagande
anti-française sur le continent africain
donnons-nous les moyens de le combattre
et de le vaincre avec nos partenaires
européens aujourd'hui seul 11 membres du
groupe Wagner sont sous sanctions ils
sont 9000 à travers le monde et plus de
50 000 déployés en Ukraine avec des
chars d'assaut des hélicoptères et des
avions de combat il faut nommer les
choses
l'activité du groupe Wagner répond à la
définition européenne du terrorisme
intimidé des populations civiles
contraindre indument des pouvoirs
publics gravement déstabilisés ou
détruire des institutions à travers
cette résolution nous nous appelons les
autorités européennes à renforcer
considérablement leur coopération et
leurs instruments judiciaires financiers
pour faire la lumière sur cette
organisation tentaculaire et opaque
lutter contre Wagner et ceux qui rendent
ces opérations possibles mettre fin à
ses activités l'inscription sur la liste
des groupes terroristes de l'Union
répond à cet objectif certains de nos
partenaires comme les États-Unis
n'hésitent pas à utiliser la force de
leurs droits et leurs instruments
financiers pour défendre leurs intérêts
et leur sécurité à travers le monde à
nouveau régime de sanctions inspiré du
statut d'organisation criminelle
transnationale qu'utilisent les
Américains pourraient aussi être
explorés c'est à la France de mener ce
combat notre Assemblée nationale peut
être à l'avant-garde d'une campagne
européenne et je remercie le groupe
renaissance de porter cette résolution
mais je salue aussi les députés des
groupes modem hor
qui le soutiennent et qui montre que
pour soutenir nos valeurs démocratiques
notre hémicycle c'est se rassembler oui
la France doit mener ce combat parce que
nous avons été désignés par Wagner comme
l'ennemi numéro 1 et cela depuis des
années avant la guerre d'agression en
Ukraine du 24 février cela alors que le
rassemblement national proposait
toujours l'alliance avec la Russie dans
son programme faiblesse naïveté
complicité toutes les positions
opportunistes que vous afficherez
aujourd'hui ou demain tous les
retournements de vestes ne feront
oublier à personne votre indulgence
coupable pendant des années vous voulez
sortir des alliances vous n'aimez pas
l'Europe très bien nous nous pensons que
les menaces contre nos frères européens
sont des menaces contre nous-mêmes que
la France grandit à être avec ses
partenaires que c'est dans son intérêt
mais là ce n'est pas l'Allemagne
l'Estonie ou les États-Unis qui étaient
visés c'était la France et pourtant vous
étiez de l'autre côté
oui c'est à la France de mener ce combat
car nous portons haut et fort le projet
d'une Europe qui se défend qui renforce
les instruments sur le plan économique
militaire technologique mais aussi
juridique pour assumer sa souveraineté
et sa sécurité seul si nécessaire quand
ces alliés lui font défaut la France
doit être la voie du roi armement mental
et matériel du continent d'une Europe
qui refuse d'être un théâtre passif des
rivalités des grandes puissances de
sortir de l'histoire d'une Europe qui ne
laisse pas son voisinage de la
Méditerranée à l'Afrique des Balkans à
l'Europe de l'Est rapacité des régimes
autoritaires une Europe qui assume sa
puissance c'est le sens de notre combat
avec le président de la République
depuis 6 ans oui c'est à la France de
mener ce combat parce que la voix de la
France doit toujours être du côté de la
justice et de la liberté
la parole est à Monsieur Jérôme buisson
du groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur l'Ambassadeur d'Ukraine mes
chers collègues le groupe Wagner comme
l'ensemble des sociétés militaires
privées à travers le monde connaît un
essor rapide au gré des signatures de
nouveaux contrats menant à des
engagements dans un nombre croissant de
pays si nous constatons que ces sociétés
sont souvent pour les états un outil de
leur politique étrangère le groupe
Wagner et quant à lui une arme au
service du pouvoir russe une arme qui
déstabilise certains pays africains en
prélevant directement les ressources
naturelles en guise de rémunération une
arme qui attaque directement les
intérêts de la France dans les pays
africains et pratiques la désinformation
pour dénigrer l'armée française
selon des experts du haut-commissaire
des Nations Unies aux droits de l'homme
c'est probablement l'arme qui tue des
centaines de civils maliens à Moura et
ombori enfin ces larmes qui sévit depuis
le 24 février 2022 en Ukraine celle qui
mène depuis quelques mois l'offensive à
bakoumount le groupe Wagner est donc une
entité qui attaque les intérêts français
déstabilisent les pays dans lequel il
intervient et il commet selon des
experts des exactions pour tout crimes
de guerre nous demandons que soit
systématiquement diligenté des enquêtes
internationales indépendantes sous
l'égide des Nations unies ou de la Cour
pénale internationale des enquêtes à
même d'établir les responsabilités des
crimes
il nous paraît clair que ce groupe
paramilitaire atteint nos intérêts
nationaux et que certaines de ces
actions revêtent un caractère illégal
voire criminel pour le respect de nos
intérêts comme du droit international le
groupe rassemblement national votre a
cette proposition de résolution
toutefois nous déplorons une nouvelle
fois la dimension hors sol voire même
incantatoire que prend notre politique
étrangère cette résolution invite
notamment le gouvernement à se mobiliser
pour demander l'inscription du groupe
Wagner sur la liste de l'Union
européenne des organisations terroristes
la portée réelle de cette classification
du groupe Wagner nous semble limiter
cette entité n'ayant pas d'existence
légale au sein de l'Union européenne et
ses dirigeants faisant déjà l'objet de
sanctions
cette résolution révèle donc du symbole
nous connaissons tous leur importance
mais le symbole ne fait pas l'action mes
chers collègues pour faire reculer le
groupe Wagner en Afrique où la Russie
nous mène une guerre d'influence les
résolutions ne nous aiderons guère
nous devons réinvestir notre partenariat
avec les pays africains dans le cadre de
relation bilatérales respectueuse de la
souveraineté des États contrer la
propagande anti-française et construire
une politique de co-développement
permettant de stabiliser ses pays la
lutte contre le groupe Wagner comme
l'ensemble de la politique étrangère de
la nation ne peut être une succession de
postures et d'incantation nous ne devons
pas comme on a pris l'habitude le
président de la République venir en
Afrique exposer les canons de la
gouvernance et enchaîner les sorties
teinte de paternalisme voire même de
mépris ces envolés verbales relèvent
encore une fois du symbole mais un
symbole qui entache gravement nos
relations diplomatiques par ces actions
le président Macron est un acteur de
notre perte d'influence ainsi que de
l'effondrement de nos échanges
commerciaux avec les pays du continent
malheureusement cette déroute
diplomatique de la diplomatie
présidentielle laisse place à d'autres
acteurs comme la Chine et la Russie nous
devons au même titre que les autres
puissances du monde manier les leviers
diplomatiques économiques militaires
culturel ou informationnels qui sont à
notre disposition
pourtant bien qu'ayant subit une
politique désastreuse à bien des égards
la France ne manque pas d'atouts nous
disposons encore du troisième réseau
diplomatique au monde notre langue le
français et la langue la plus parlée de
la Francophonie et sera un des piliers
de la politique étrangère conduite par
notre Président nous avons de nombreux
groupes présents dans les secteurs
stratégiques et enfin nous avons une
armée puissante disposant d'une capacité
de projection
en tant que force d'alternance le
rassemblement national prône pour la
nation une politique indépendante
proactive intransigeante sur nos
intérêts mais conservant la retenue et
le professionnalisme caractéristique de
l'art de la diplomatie en votant cette
PPR nous souhaitons affirmer réaffirmer
la voix singulière de la France dans le
concierge des nations notre attachement
à la défense de nos intérêts et aux
droits international ainsi que notre
soutien sans ambiguïté à l'Ukraine
agressée par la Russie à travers ce
groupe paramilitaire je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame merciia soudé du
groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur chers collègues la France
comme toute grande nation se doit de
mettre les moyens de sa puissance au
service de l'intérêt général du peuple
humain seul la coopération
internationale peut endiguer les menaces
qui pèsent sur l'humanité que ce soit au
niveau du changement climatique des
guerres des pandémies la guerre que mène
la Russie de Poutine contre l'Ukraine a
rebattu toutes les cartes de la
diplomatie européenne voire
internationale
parmi ces pions il en possède un qu'il a
toujours eu du mal à reconnaître
voir parfois à contrôler le groupe
Wagner une société militaire privée qui
agit dans une demi obscurité depuis 2014
partout la Russie pourrait avoir des
intérêts principalement économiques que
ce soit au Mali en Libye en Centre
Afrique en Syrie encore un Ukraine
Wagner c'est tristement illustré par ses
exactions à l'encontre des populations
civiles locales il s'agit d'exécution de
viol ou encore de pillage il est de
l'autre devoir de parlementaire de
dénoncer ces crimes de guerre oui frigo
Jean est un criminel de guerre et son
organisation également nous condamnons
les miles Wagner ainsi que la guerre
insupportable menée par Poutine contre
l'Ukraine la France et l'Union
européenne va de vrai pour la paix
c'était le sens notamment du vote pour
de nos parlementaires européens de la
France insoumise quant à l'amendement
qui déclarait que les attaques
délibérées et les atrocités commises par
la Russie contre la population civile de
l'Ukraine constitue des actes de terreur
et des crimes de guerre
aujourd'hui chers collègues vous nous
demandez de nous positionner sur le fait
que Wagner soit une organisation
terroriste permettez-moi déjà de nous
interroger collectivement l'impression
de se qualificatif ne laisse dubitatif
ce terme de terroriste renvoie une
réalité politique et juridique précise
mais vous l'avez tellement galvaudé nous
saisissons la portée symbolique de votre
texte cependant le Parlement européen
c'est déjà penché sur la question la
France ne possédant pas de liste
d'organisations terroristes et cela se
joue maintenant au niveau du Conseil de
l'Europe qui peine à trancher on
rappellera d'ailleurs que les États-Unis
eux-mêmes ont renoncé à cet appellation
n'avez-vous pas peur que la portée
symbolique de ce texte ne se heurte
fortement au principe de réalité d'autre
part les 10 premières sociétés
militaires privées sont américaines
britanniques et canadiennes que ce soit
Blackwater blackshield ou Wagner elles
sont toutes dans le viseur de la justice
pour des crimes de guerre de ce fait
nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi seul
Wagner doit être inscrite sur la liste
européenne des organisations terroristes
nous condamnons unanimement tous les
crimes de guerre quel qu'il soit et
appelons à mettre le sujet sur la table
pour toutes ces sociétés militaires
privées c'est pourquoi nous refusons de
cautionner une indication à géométrie
variable ce qu'il faut dénoncer c'est la
privatisation de la guerre qui permet
aux sociétés aux États la France y
compris il faut balayer devant sa porte
de se défausser de la responsabilité de
l'usage de la violence et de la force
pour reprendre les mots de l'ONG ou
Aaron want on n'oublie pas le mercenaire
français Bob Denard par exemple impliqué
dans de nombreux coups d'État en Afrique
par ailleurs Wagner est de plus en plus
présente sur ce continent ce groupe est
devenu un véritable outil géopolitique
et géostratégique de la Russie Wagner a
peu à peu remplacer les militaires de
l'ONU de l'OTAN ou de la France dans ces
pays ne risque-t-on pas de saliner tous
ces pays africains ont déclarant que
leur principal sous-traitants de
sécurité intérieure est une organisation
terroriste surtout que dans certains
pays le ressentiment anti français comme
pays colonialiste est déjà très fort
enfin les Wagner League ont démontré
comment la galaxie Prigogine s'était
tendue bien au-delà des activités par un
militaires notamment en Afrique frigojin
est aujourd'hui à la tête d'une
organisation de plus de 400 sociétés
japonais par le Concorde groupe les
sanctions ont été prises par l'Union
européenne pour bloquer les actifs de ce
chien de guerre mais quelle efficacité
peut-on leur attribuer lui-même les
juges raisonnable il y a sûrement là un
sujet de réflexion que nous devons
sérieusement étudier car oui ce qui
nourrit le mercenaria c'est la recherche
du profit le capitalisme porte en lui la
guerre comme la nuée porte l'orage vous
dirais Jean Jaurès
d'ailleurs c'est bien la raison pour
laquelle le groupe Wagner cherche à se
retirer du conflit ukrainien comme un
atteste plusieurs articles de presse
récents finalement la rentabilité
espérée n'est pas au rendez-vous encore
une fois nous n'avons aucun souci à
reconnaître les crimes de guerre de cet
organisation tout en ayant conscience
que cette résolution relève
essentiellement de la déclaration
d'intention et que la symbolique
l'emporte sur la sémantique mais vous
chers collègues seriez-vous prêt à
engager une démarche d'ampleur comme les
Britanniques pour examiner au cas par
cas toutes les milices privées et pour
renforcer la lutte contre les sociétés
mercenaires auxquelles la France et des
soucis des Françaises ont parfois
recours elles-mêmes c'était le sens de
la proposition de résolution que la
Guinée équatoriale a soumis en 2019
assez perd du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU qui visait à renforcer la lutte
contre les mercenaires dans le centre de
l'Afrique
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Vincent c'est un G du groupe et
républicain
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires étrangères mes chers
collègues en préambule je souhaiterais
saluer le travail de qualité réalisé par
notre collègue Benjamin Haddad et le
remercier pour ce texte dont le vote
honorera cette assemblée quel symbole
que ce texte soit discuté le 9 mai jour
de l'Europe l'Europe de Robert Schuman
député de la Moselle comme moi qui
défendit le principe d'union des peuples
par la culture par le commerce et non
par les armes comme le souhaite
aujourd'hui Wagner alors il revient
aujourd'hui à la représentation
nationale de se prononcer sur la
proposition de résolution visant à
appeler la France et l'Union européenne
a inscrire le groupe militaire privé
Wagner sur la liste des organisations
terroristes
la ministre russe privée Wagner opère
sur les zones de guerre avec pour
mission sinon de défendre les intérêts
du Kremlin dans sa guerre d'influence du
moins de vendre sommersunaria au
potentat des pays dans lequel à
intervient Wagner alimente la violence
puis les ressources massacres les civils
et ce endulation constante du droit
international partout ou pas de Wagner
on entrevoit ce qu'il y a de pire chez
l'homme Wagner ce sont les mises à mort
sommaires de rebelles syrien Wagner ce
sont les tirs du haut d'hélicoptère sur
les Maliens des armées de Moura Wagner
ce sont les massacres en Ukraine de
Bucha Wagner ce sont ses soldats
goguenard mutilant leur prisonniers de
guerre je cherche la dignité des mots
qui pourraient faire parvenir dans cette
hémicycle la réalité des souffrances de
l'humiliation de la néantisation de
l'être
que sont les mots pour raconter la nuit
des âmes l'assassinat de civils des
armées
par delà cet abîme il nous faudrait
pouvoir plonger dans les profondeurs
ténébreuses de la conscience humaine
pour comprendre
mes Wagner c'est également le symbole de
la dégénérescence d'un pays en mal
d'influence
à l'image de son chef elle gagne
Prigogine repris de justice multicondée
devenu chef d'entreprise proche du
Kremlin avant de se lancer dans la
défense par un militaire
aujourd'hui nous sommes réunis
car il s'agit de combattre le groupe
Wagner par la justice
afin de savoir s'il peut être placé sur
la liste des organisations terroristes
au-delà de apporter symbolique de cette
décision cela permettrait d'une part de
consacrer contre cette officine les
outils européens de lutte contre le
terrorisme
d'autre part de gelées ces avoir dans
l'Union européenne et d'interdire aux
entités y étant établies de mettre des
fonds à sa disposition
ce dispositif est d'autant plus efficace
que nous sommes dans le contexte d'une
guerre hybride que nous faisons face à
une société par un militaire privée qui
doit payer ces mercenaires or une grande
partie de ces fonds transit par l'Europe
et si nos sanctions venaient s'ajouter à
celles des États-Unis cela permettrait
d'asphyxier la capacité de nuisance du
groupe Wagner en le privant de
ressources financières
alors pour décider si Wagner doit être
placé sur cette liste des organisations
terroristes il faut se référer à la
définition du Conseil de l'Union
européenne qui précise que les atteintes
à la vie d'une personne sont qualifiées
de terroristes lorsqu'elles sont
commises dans le but de gravement
intimider une population ou de détruire
les structures politiques d'un pays or
la communauté internationale accumulée
assez de preuves les ONG les services de
renseignement la presse ont déjà
documenté assez de faits pour démontrer
que Wagner est une organisation
terroriste en conséquence le groupe les
républicains votera en faveur de cette
proposition de résolution
au delà de la nécessité d'une telle
décision c'est la capacité de l'Europe à
faire preuve de résilience qui sera
mesurée
cette résolution sans ambiguïté cette
parole officielle durable constitue nous
les cyrons une première étape sur le
chemin qui verra monsieur Prigogine et
tous les oligarques du crime seul dans
leur barbarie répondre à la justice de
tous je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric petit
du groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
depuis février 2022 nous pouvons mettre
enfin des mots concrets et du sens sur
des valeurs que certains
qualifient de fumeuses nous disent après
tout les valeurs européennes c'est des
choses qui ont été imaginées c'est des
choses qui existent ailleurs ils sont
élus je prends souvent l'exemple de la
langue de nos fameuses 24 langues
émancipatrice chez nous assignation à
résidence dans l'impérialisme où
l'histoire qui est une science chez nous
l'information qui est un partage alors
que ce sont des armes de guerre dans du
côté impérialiste
dans le cas du groupe Wagner nous
touchons une question absolument
fondamentale en démocratie et dans nos
valeurs qui se bat
nos soldats en démocratie sont d'abord
et avant tout des citoyennes et des
citoyens pas des commerçants pas des
prisonniers on se bat pour son pays pour
sa nation
on ne se bat pas pour son patron ou pour
soi-même
dès 2018 la commission des affaires
étrangères de notre assemblée sous la
présidence de Marielle de Sarnez c'était
intéressé à ce phénomène des proxy
assaison de guerre ou la lutte armée
devient business en Syrie en Irak en
Libye y compris chez les Américains
chers collègues nous ne étions posé
cette question
que peut devenir la démocratie quand ce
ne sont plus les États qui commandent
les armées que peut devenir la
diplomatie
Wagner a été créé en 2014 dans le
Donbass
c'est une gestion d'entreprise privée
avec même un plan stratégique de sa
division Afrique comme des grandes
entreprises il y a un plan stratégique
de la division Afrique de Wagner que des
journalistes courageux nous ont permis
auxquels des journalistes courageuses
que je salue aussi nous ont permis
d'accéder
certes nous avons tous que sur les
théâtres d'opérations
Wagner massacre pire saccage viol des
crimes de guerre de plus en plus
documentées en Syrie au Liban Soudan en
Centrafrique comme Mozambique au Mali et
en Ukraine le groupe scène la terreur
mais une fois installé
conformément au business plan de
l'entreprise à la stratégie des chefs
d'entreprise j'insiste le groupe Wagner
se lance dans l'exploitation des
ressources minières
orifères le bois je ne serai pas surpris
outre mesure chers collègues que le
détour que les armées de Wagner ont fait
par Solidar avant en s'avançant vers
darkmouth
ne s'avère une opération économique et
que nous ayons aujourd'hui des
prisonniers qui soient au fond de la
mine et pas en train de se battre
et mes chers collègues ce groupe est lié
à l'armée russe quoi qu'on nous en
raconte d'abord parce que il y a des
concurrences entre des armées privées il
n'y a pas que Wagner le ministre des
Affaires le ministre des armées russes a
aussi la sienne Gazprom est en train de
construire les siennes donc ils sont au
moins liés comme des concurrents d'un
même business mais surtout ils sont
utilisés comme ballon d'essai comme un
laboratoire de qui peut de ce qui peut
se faire ou ne pas se faire avec des
exemples très concrets en 2014
je vais dans le don-basse sans y être et
je regarde la réaction internationale 8
ans après j'envahis je crée j'essaie
d'aller chercher quartier avec une
opération soi-disant spéciale
l'incorporation des prisonniers deuxième
exemple on considère qu'il y a 40000
prisonniers qui ont été recrutés par
Wagner dans les prisons aujourd'hui ce
ne sont plus
Wagner qui va dans les prisons proposer
des contrats c'est l'armée russe
mais Wagner c'est une entreprise
certainement lucrative mais c'est une
mauvaise armée une bonne armée repose de
toute façon sur l'engagement des
citoyens
à chaque confrontation de terrain
vaguener et battu au Mali ils ont avancé
parce que nous ne voulions pas nous
engager dans un combat trouble ils ont
été écrasés dans les quelques
accrochages en Syrie avec l'armée
américaine et ils ont été arrêtés en
Ukraine mes chers collègues ne nous
trompons pas ce n'est pas une armée
d'élite ce n'est pas une armée puissante
c'est un bras armé d'un pouvoir mafieux
cupide et profondément cynique alors oui
il est important que la France et
l'Europe est une parole forte sur ses
groupes sur ce phénomène de
sous-traitance de la guerre de ses anti
start-up de cette économie innovante et
macabre
inscrire Wagner sur la liste des groupes
terroristes ce n'est que du droit
effectivement ce n'est que du droit mais
c'est du droit et c'est notre arme parce
qu'une menace plus qu'une menace pour
nos intérêts le groupe Wagner est une
menace pour notre modèle le groupe
démocrate votera donc en faveur de cette
résolution je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Alain David du
groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur du crâne
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires étrangères monsieur le
rapporteur chers
la proposition de résolution que nous
examinons aujourd'hui a pour objet de
demander à la France et à l'Union
européenne l'inscription du groupe
militaire privé Wagner sur la liste des
organisations terroristes
ce groupe créé en 2014 dans le cadre de
l'annexion de la Crimée et de la guerre
dans le Dombas par la Fédération de
Russie et financée dirigée par
l'oligarque russe Prigogine proche de
Poutine
les miliciens du groupe Wagner se sont
tristement distingués
en étant particulièrement actif en Syrie
au travers d'entraînement mais également
d'opérations de combat direct en soutien
au régime de Bachar el-Assad
par la suite ils ont développé leurs
activités en Afrique et concrètement ce
groupe fonctionne comme une mélisse
armée financée par les gouvernements qui
font appel et par des activités de
prédation économiques récupération des
mineurs de diamant vente d'alcool trafic
d'animaux etc leur contrat avec les
gouvernements vise également à des
activités d'influence de désinformation
et de déstabilisation
pour cela en plus des fameuses fermes de
trolls pour mener des campagnes de
propagande sur internet ils emploient la
violence armée et commettent de graves
atteintes aux droits humains à
l'encontre des populations civiles et
d'opposants politiques d'autres
collègues et notre rapporteur ont
détaillé par exemple ce qui s'est
pratiqué en Syrie au Mali ou en Centre
Afrique dans le cadre de la Fédération
de Russie et de l'agression de l'Ukraine
Wagner sert de milice parallèle à
l'armée régulière selon le journal
allemand d’her Spiegel les services de
renseignement allemand auraient dans
leur procession
le les conversations provenant la
présence à bout de chat de miliciens du
groupe lors du massacre en y faisant
référence
forte d'environ 9000 hommes partout dans
le monde jusqu'à fin 2021 la guerre en
Ukraine a démultiplié le nombre de
soldats de Wagner
pas moins de 50000 mercenaires sont
aujourd'hui présents en Ukraine cette
croissance exponentielle c'est
probablement fait par le recrutement
problématique de 40 000 reprises une
vidéo divise
en septembre 2022 montre Peggy parlant
des prisonniers d'une colonie de
pénitentiaire russe et leur proposant le
contrat suivant si vous faites 6 mois en
Ukraine vous êtes libre mais si vous n'y
arrivez pas et que vous décidez que ce
n'est pas pour vous alors nous vous
exécuteront
il y a quelques semaines une fuite de
documents internes au groupe les Wagner
lixes
a permis de confirmer certaines
informations en particulier en ce qui
concerne leurs opérations de
déstabilisation et d'influence dans le
processus électoraux mais aussi sur
leurs achats d'armes la milice a été
sanctionnée par l'Union européenne en
2021-2023 dans le viseur du FBI à cause
de leur ingérence reconnue dans les
élections américaines de 2016 et de 2020
pour ces raisons la PPR invite le
gouvernement à se mobiliser
diplomatiquement auprès de l'Union
européenne afin d'inscrire l'entité
militaire privée Wagner sur la liste
l'Union européenne des organisations
terroristes cette inscription sur la
liste de l'Union européenne permettra de
faciliter les sanctions contre le groupe
les violations graves au droit humain et
la pratique de la terreur
contre les populations civiles nombreux
pays les preuves accumulées quant à la
responsabilité dans des massacres de
plusieurs centaines de personnes à Moura
au Mali à bout de chat en Ukraine leur
présence et influence croissantes dans
de nombreuses régions du monde leur
capacités réelles et effectives
d'ingérence dans les processus
électoraux documentés et confirmés
laisse peu de doute quant à la nécessité
de placer ce groupe militaire privé sur
la liste des organisations terroristes
ce classement serait également un signal
important vu
l'instrumentalisation
revendiquée du sentiment anti-français
et plus globalement antioxydantal de
cette milice sur le continent africain
et ses velléités ailleurs dans le monde
pour toutes ces raisons avec mes
collègues du groupe des députés
socialistes et apparentés nous voterons
bien sûr en faveur de ce texte merci
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Stéphanie cocher
du groupe horizon
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur l'Ambassadeur monsieur le
Président bourlange mes chers collègues
exécution sommaire exaction crime de
guerre voilà l'actif du groupe Wagner
organisation par un militaire qui œuvre
au Proche-Orient au Venezuela en Afrique
et tout dernièrement en Ukraine
cette organisation n'a pas d'identité
juridique c'est une société fantôme
irresponsable devant le droit
international agissant hors de tout
cadre juridique c'est une menace pour la
sécurité mondiale
une menace d'abord et avant tout car les
mercenaires agissant sous la bannière de
cette organisation se sont rendus
coupables des actes les plus ignobles
comment peut-on désigner autrement
l'exécution de civils lors de la
bataille de Tripoli les massacres au
Mali et en Centrafrique
une menace ensuite car il mène une
guerre hybride contre notre nation nous
institutions démocratiques et celles de
nos partenaires européens ce sont des
professionnels de la désinformation
ils ont uniquement créé de toutes pièces
une fausse commune au Mali tentant de
décrédibiliser l'action de l'armée
française en l'accusant des actions
mais la mensonge vont bien au-delà car à
ces agissements criminels s'ajoutent les
usines atrolles les milieux de faux
comptes créés sur les réseaux sociaux
remettant en cause les fondamentaux de
notre démocratie et diffusant
massivement la propagande du Kremlin une
menace enfin car ils sont une branche de
facto du ministère de la Défense russe
ils ont beau mettre en scène lors des
Accords la Russie équipe les mercenaires
de Wagner leur donnent du matériel des
munitions des infrastructures
d'entraînement mes chers collègues c'est
assemblés à adopter le 30 novembre
dernier une résolution condamnant
l'agression de l'Ukraine par la Russie
nous y donnions la stratégie des
terreurs de la Russie
cette stratégie de terreur s'appuie sur
un bras armé par la même logique ce bras
armé est une organisation terroriste
huit Wagner est une organisation
terroriste aussi car son action
correspond en tout point à la définition
consacrée par les institutions
européennes
l'Union européenne qualifie comme acte
terroriste se commis pour gravement
intimider une population pour
contraindre indument les pouvoirs
publics ou pour déstabiliser ou détruire
des structures politiques
constitutionnelles économique ou sociale
fondamentale d'un pays
mes chers collègues c'est un fait
partout Wagner est implanté la
population est mise en danger les
mercenaires utilisent des tactiques
brutales et inhumaines assassinat
ciblées enlèvement exécution sommaire
en outre le groupe Wagner fait pression
sur les pouvoirs publics par la violence
l'intimidation et la corruption ils sont
devenus la garde prétorienne des
dictatures militaires en Afrique il
s'approprie les ressources naturelles
comme une puissance coloniale d'un
nouveau genre au service d'eveny
privogine
enfin la simple implication de Wagner
dans la guerre en Ukraine l'une des plus
grandes opérations de
déstabilisation d'une démocratie
européenne depuis la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale devrait suffire à nous
convaincre de la nature de son action
c'est donc en toute cohérence que nous
devons appeler comme le fait la présente
proposition de résolution à ce que le
groupe Wagner soit inscrite sur la liste
des organisations terroristes de l'Union
européenne
les institutions européennes et
internationales doivent continuer à
enquêter sur les multiples exactions de
cette organisation paramilitaire nous
devons aussi renforcer notre capacité à
lutter contre les actions d'influence de
ce groupe chez nos partenaires et alliés
le groupe horizon et apparenté votre a
donc en faveur de cette proposition de
résolution je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Julien
Bayou du groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
ministre monsieur l'Ambassadeur chers
collègues
beaucoup de choses ont été dites sur les
atrocités commises par la milice Wagner
aussi je me permettrai d'utiliser mon
temps un peu pour élargir le sujet parce
que depuis de longues années la Russie
va Dimir Poutine menace l'équilibre du
monde et met en péril les intérêts de la
paix et de la stabilité mondiale depuis
de longues années ces Moscou qui full au
pied les normes les plus élémentaires du
droit international tout compte tout en
continuant à être invité à la table de
nos dirigeants et réussit ainsi à
imposer son rythme de désordre et de
déséquilibre
et la France doit le reconnaître
malheureusement à longtemps péché par sa
naïveté alors qu'il suffit de se
retourner sur les années récentes de
l'histoire du continent européen pour y
trouver les crimes de guerre les crimes
contre l'humanité et les crimes
d'agression que nous devons
à la Russie dès les années 2000 c'est la
ville de Rosny enchénie qui a été rasé
de la carte après des mois de
bombardements intensifs et les
principales victimes étaient des civils
en 2008 la Russie a envahi militairement
la Géorgie et a voulu soi-disant
légitimer son action en reconnaissant
l'indépendance d'entité séparatistes
séparatiste par la protection supposée
des populations russes sur ce territoire
en 2014 à nouveau
une soi-disant protection de population
russe la Russie décrète l'annexion de la
Crimée par un référendum pseudo
référendum ceux d'occupation militaire
certains parlementaires ici se sont
déshonorés à reconnaître les résultats
de ce référendum
il y a déclenché le conflit du Dombas on
la souveraineté et l'intérité
territoriale de l'Ukraine et en 2015
nous avons assisté impuissant au crime
de la Russie en Syrie
donc nous savions qu'un tel dictateur ne
pouvait être résonné Emmanuel Macron le
président a cru lui qu'il pouvait tout
seul et contre tous influencer les actes
de Poutine il l'a reçu avec tous les
honneurs au cœur de notre patrimoine à
Versailles en 2017 et ensuite dans le
fort de Brégançon dans une volonté de
réinitialiser les relations avec la
Russie péché d'orgueil
sans égard pour la diplomatie européenne
il a cru naïvement pouvoir le ramener à
la raison lors d'entretien médiatisé mis
en scène
dans une tentative médiatique et
politique de se mettre au coeur du jeu
européen contre la vie de nos
partenaires et le résultat n'en est que
plus amer ce dialogue privilégié n'a pas
pu empêcher le pire le 24 février 2022
l'agression russe de l'Ukraine et une
guerre qui dure désormais depuis plus
d'un an la naïveté de la politique
française
reposant sur une médiation veine et
l'idée qu'une sortie honorable doit être
trouvée au dictateur Poutine nous fait
perdre de vue l'objectif premier la
Russie doit perdre cette guerre
l'Ukraine doit gagner la démocratie doit
prévaloir
ouvrir les yeux sur la réalité de la
guerre avant qu'il ne soit trop tard ce
que le président de la République semble
avoir des désormais compris tant mieux
il y a peu lors de la 59e conférence de
Munich sur la sécurité Emmanuel Macron a
déclaré à propos du groupe Wagner je
cite ses propos le président Poutine me
disait ces jantes Wagner ils ne sont pas
à nous ils nous posent aussi des
problèmes en Russie et il ajoutait qu'il
accordait du crédit à l'époque à cette
déclaration qu'il croyait le président
Poutine là était la naïveté et il
poursuivait dans sa déclaration je cite
ils ont maintenant officialisé le fait
que Wagner était un truchement explicite
direct diplomatique aux militaire
néomafieux de la Russie partout dans le
monde cette prise de conscience est
salutaire même si elle est tardive
la milice privée Wagner était déjà
active dès 2014 en Crimée et dans le
don-basse cette prise de conscience
salutaire sera j'espère le signe du
naïveté enfin révolu aujourd'hui au delà
des divergences qui peuvent exister
entre nous y compris des parties qui ont
été financés par le Kremlin nous nous
retrouvons sur le constat que ces
exasations et ses crimes ne doivent pas
être passé sous silence
nous soutenons donc pour en finir la
proposition de résolution et je salue le
travail de notre collègue
Haddad pour inscrire cette entité
militaire privée sur liste européenne
des organisations terroristes et traquer
les dirigeants membres et soutient de
Wagner il faut pouvoir saisir
directement leurs avoir la liste est
trop longue des oligarques russes
soutien de sorte organisation qui
profite impunément des stations de ski
pour les sports d'hiver ou des ports
français pour l'amarrage de leur yacht
produit de la corruption et de la
prédation j'attends du gouvernement qui
donne donc des suites des actes à ce
signe fort que nous envoyons aujourd'hui
il faut lutter contre la milice Wagner
autant que contre ces donneurs d'ordre
les traités comme ceux qu'ils sont des
complices d'un état criminel que nous
devons désormais considérer par ailleurs
des Nations Unies
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq
du groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
la Présidente
c'est le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères mes chers collègues
cette proposition de résolution visant à
appeler la France et l'Union européenne
inscrire le groupe militaire privé
Wagner sur la liste des organisations
terroristes est une excellente
opportunité pour revenir sur les
entreprises de sécurité privée
si l'emploi de mercenaire a toujours été
un outil utilisé depuis que les guerres
entre état existent on assiste depuis la
montée en puissance du néolibéralisme
des années 1980 à une explosion de
l'usage des entreprises militaires
privées
pratique à utiliser pour ne pas s'avouer
responsable de telle ou telle opération
et pour faire croire que la guerre n'a
pas fait de mort ces entreprises
absorbent aujourd'hui des sommes
colossales d'argent public on
Afghanistan en 2011 il y avait même plus
de personnels de ces entreprises privées
que de militaires américains 113.000
contre 90 000 en Irak ces derniers ont
même bénéficié d'une immunité d'une
immunité légale ce qui a entraîné de
graves débordements comme la des
exécutions de dizaines de civils
commises notamment par l'entreprise
Blackwater et même des codes torture
notamment par l'entreprise c'est assezi
qui a fourni des tortionnaires à la
tristement célèbre prison d'Abou Grabi à
graïbe
depuis quelques années la tension s'est
déplacée vers la Russie et la compagnie
Wagner Wagner c'est le surnom du
fondateur de ce groupe militaire Dimitri
outkine un ancien officier du
renseignement militaire russe néo-nazi
qui a choisi ce surnom en hommage au
compositeur préféré d'Hitler Wagner
c'est surtout le symbole de la porosité
de la frontière entre civil et
combattants
de l'effacement des frontières entre la
paix et la guerre et de la nouvelle
guerre qui se mène sur tous les champs
et dans tous les milieux des
informations cyber combat armées etc au
départ Wagner n'était d'ailleurs qu'un
outil de désinformation porté par les
progo
cet outil servait à relayer la
communication officielle russe et la
propagande visant à affaiblir les
adversaires et à mobiliser les pros
russes dans des espaces disputés comme
dans le dos basse où en Ukraine puis le
groupe s'est implanté en Afrique et en
Syrie en Centrafrique malheureusement le
travail de propagande n'a d'ailleurs pas
été difficile pour eux tant l'État
français n'a jamais été capable de
comprendre son rôle délétère dans ses
anciennes colonies étant l'État français
n'a jamais voulu voir que sa politique
militaire économique et monétaire en
Afrique était totalement rejeté par les
populations peu à peu des machines de
propagande Wagner un rajouter un pilier
militaire sans jamais avoir d'existence
juridique et légale
ce flou lui permet d'être en Russie
malgré l’interdiction en Russie du
mercenaria cela lui permet également
d'éviter en tant que groupe la question
de sa responsabilité juridique et légale
quant à ses crimes
c'est ce qui pose d'ailleurs un grave
problème car les crimes de masse les
plus odieux commis par Wagner ont été
documentés au plus haut niveau notamment
aux Nations Unies et leur culpabilité ne
semble pas pouvoir être mis en doute
c'est pourquoi le groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine votre a pour
cette résolution
en espérant toutefois que l'Union
européenne entendent cette demande et
que les restrictions de mouvement de
personnel et les gels des avoir puissent
être véritablement efficace mais
attention à ne pas faire de Wagner
l'arbre qui cache la forêt
le monde des entreprises militaires
privées et constellée d'entreprises
violentes au contour flou et qui
agissent dans des zones grises de la
légalité internationale beaucoup d'entre
elles ont violé des droits et commis des
crimes dans différentes théâtres
d'opérations par conséquent cette
résolution regagnant force si elle avait
demandé à l'exécutif de s'engager en
plus de vos recommandations sur Wagner
sur un travail diplomatique visant à
mieux encadrer ce secteur dans son
ensemble par exemple en renforçant le
statut juridique du document de Montreux
et le groupe de travail des Nations
Unies consacrées à ce sujet car la
privatisation de fonction régaliennes
comme les fonctions militaires devraient
rester les plus limités possible
ce combat est loin d'être gagné
évidemment mais la France sonore aurait
apporté plus fortement ce combat madame
la ministre je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Bertrand
pencher du groupe libertin indépendant
outre-mer et territoire
madame la ministre madame présidente
madame la ministre sur le rapporteur
cher collègues la société Wagner fondée
par trigogine il y a de cela près de 10
ans n'a cessé depuis lors de
déstabiliser les États et de perpétrer
des crimes de guerre contre l'humanité
j'aimerais d'abord revenir sur les
multiples terrain d'opérations où cette
milice est intervenue d'abord bien sûr
en Ukraine en 2014 le groupe a apporté
un soutien militaire aux forces
séparatistes de Crimée en infraction
avec le droit international aujourd'hui
et depuis 2022 le groupe participe aux
opérations militaires sur le terrain on
soutient aux forces régulières de la
Fédération de Russie son rôle dans les
multiples massacres et atrocités
découvert comme un bout de chat et de
mieux en mieux documenté
ensuite au sel ou Wagner mène de fausses
opérations de maintien de l'ordre pour
dissimuler ces deux véritables objectifs
premièrement qui est les ressources
naturelles et faire de la guerre un
business différents analystes on est
fait prouver les liens entre les
opérations de ce groupe et les
concessions pour l'exploitation de mines
de cobalt de diamants et d'or
deuxième objectif de Wagner en Afrique
le groupe entend jeté l'eau propre sur
la France en particulier sur ces
opérations extérieures contre les
menaces terroristes alors je tiens à le
rappeler les forces armées françaises
n'ont agi qu'à la demande et avec
l'accord des États concernés
rappelons d'ailleurs les succès
militaires plus que discutables de
Wagner au Mozambique non seulement sa
présence n'a pas rétabli l'ordre mais
son départ prématuré a permis à l'état
islamique de s'emparer de la région du
cabot delgato
nous pouvons avoir les plus grandes
craintes pour le Mali donc dirigeant
pucciste se sert de Wagner comme
garantie de maintien de son pouvoir
personnel
enfin il faut faire toute la lumière sur
l'implication de Wagner dans les
élections c'est dernières années
plusieurs enquêtes le soupçonnent Wagner
de graves tentatives de déstabilisation
d'élections démocratique c'est faire ma
troll aurait ainsi participé à une
guerre de l'information lors de la
présidentielle américaine de 2016 le
groupe aurait également manipulé les
élections malgaches de 2018 et enfin
chers collègues ce groupe aurait aussi
tenté de déstabiliser la campagne
électorale française des présidentielles
en 2017
le groupe n'est donc pas seulement
inefficace sur le terrain pour rétablir
la sécurité il met en oeuvre
tout pour rompre le pack démocratique on
se livrant à des stratégies de
désinformation et d'influence
insidieuses Wagner et là des grands
acteurs qui alimentent le sentiment
anti-français dans le monde je ne
reviendrai pas sur les relations
officieuses entre le Kremlin et cette
organisation criminelle les rangs Wagner
sont nourris par des reprises russes en
échange de réduction de peine ensuite
formé par des instructeurs de l'armée
régulière de la Fédération de Russie
pour finir comme Shera canon
alors oui les massacres de civils les
climatros blanchiment d'argent la
corruption les autorités le trucage et
la désinformation opérée durant des
élections sont autant de tentatives de
chantage sur les peuples libres et les
États indépendants et c'est à ce titre
que nous soutenons la proposition de
résolution appelant le gouvernement à
faire inscrire le groupe Wagner sur
liste des organisations terroristes de
l'Union européenne votez cette
résolution aura davantage de mobiliser
les États européens dans leur relation
bilatérales et les organisations
internationales et permettra d'alerter
sur le danger que représente cette
milice votez cette résolution c'est de
demander le gel et la saisie d'avoir du
groupe et de ses responsables et c'est
interdire l'accès à notre territoire et
demain à l'Europe aux individus liés à
cette entreprise
certes l'inscription sur liste des
organisations terroristes n'est pas
nécessaire pour de telles sanctions
soient prises mais il ne faut pas
oublier la dimension symbolique de cette
résolution car votez ce texte c'est
lutter contre les atteintes aux droits
de l'homme c'est vouloir protéger
l'organisation d'élections libres et
c'est réitérer notre soutien au peuple
ukrainien face à l'agresseur russe pour
autant l'Assemblée nationale ne peut pas
se contenter de textes déclaratoires le
groupe liote appelle l'ensemble des
représentants de la nation à œuvré à
opposer une action forte et déterminée
contre Wagner et les dirigeants de la
Fédération de Russie c'est pourquoi le
groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoires votera avec conviction la
présente résolution
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Emmanuel Ménard
madame la Présidente Monsieur Madame la
Ministre pardon Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
monsieur le rapporteur cher collègue
crâne rasé joue tombante regarde furie
nul ne peut oublier le visage de Vianney
Prigogine
le ligaque Russe proche de Vladimir
Poutine et aujourd'hui à la tête de
l'organisation par militaire Wagner
fondé en 2014 notamment par Mitry
outkine ancien membre des forces
spéciales russes et tatouées de symboles
nazis
entrée en action pour la première fois
lors de la guerre de Crimée c'est en
Afrique en Syrie et aux frontières de
l'Europe que sont implantés ces
mercenaires qui arborent des écussons
brodées d'une tête de mort poignard
entre les dents en quelques années
Wagner est passé du statut de petite
milice observée du coin de l'oeil par la
communauté internationale à une
organisation structurelle qui vend ses
services tout en développant tout en
développant une véritable machine à
cache capable de payer elle-même ses
mercenaires
en 2017 en Syrie certains membres de
Wagner avaient brillé par leur cruauté
allant jusqu'à filmer leurs exactions
les plus perverses souvenez-vous de
cette vidéo où l'on voit un déserteur
syrien torturé à coups de masse avant
d'être décapité et brûlé attachés par
les pieds après avoir été aspergé des
Sens en arrière fond de la vidéo ce sont
des hommes parlant russe que l'on entend
plaisanter sur le barbecue en
préparation l'horreur
après enquête il s'avère que l'un des
bourreaux au moins dont on voit le
visage était bien employé par la société
Wagner
en Centrafrique leur réputation et la
même sans foi ni loi il préfère tuer
plutôt que de laisser d'éventuelles
opposants derrière eux selon un récent
rapport de Human wattswatch des
massacres sont perpétrés depuis 2019 à
aiguebado en 2022 70 civils aurait été
destinés par des hommes de Wagner les
survivants parlent d'une véritable
tuerie de masse
ennemi direct de la France le groupe
Wagner ne cache pas sa volonté de nous
buter hors d'Afrique espérant ainsi
exploiter ces richesses une raison
supplémentaire pour nous montrer un
traitable
selon les services de renseignement
allemand c'est encore Wagner et ces
hommes de l'ombre qui sont responsables
des quelques 460 cadavres redécouverts
dans les fosses communes de boutcha en
Ukraine mi avril le président ukrainien
zeldenski lui-même dénonçait les
agissements de ces monstres russes après
la publication sur les réseaux sociaux
d'une vidéo montrant la décapitation
d'un prisonnier de guerre
ukrainien présumé
les accusations de cette sorte
concernant Wagner sont légion
interrogés à plusieurs reprises sur son
sujet sur ce sur le sujet Vladimir
Poutine nie toute responsabilité dans
ses exactions Wagner n'est pas l'armée
régulière russe se contente-t-il
d'affirmer elle est pourtant surnommée
l'Armée secrète de Poutine alors même
que les sociétés privées militaires sont
en principe interdites en Russie mais
Wagner a manifestement ses entrées au
Kremlin
et tout le problème est là Wagner et ces
hommes sans scrupules ont visiblement
pour mission d'effectuer les sales
besognes de l'Etat russe en novembre
dernier le Parlement européen a
d'ailleurs adopté une résolution qui
reconnaissait la Russie comme un état
soutenant le terrorisme et comme un état
qui a recours au moyen du terrorisme la
résolution a été adoptée par 494 voies
pour 58 voix contre et 44 abstention je
vous laisse regarder qui a voté contre
et qui s'est abstenu ce soutien au
terrorisme a un nom il s'appelle Wagner
terroriste bien sûr il suffit de se
référer à la définition des actes de
terrorisme rappelés par le Conseil
européen à plusieurs reprises depuis
des actes illégaux qui portent gravement
atteinte à un pays et ont pour but
d'intimider sa population ou de
gravement déstabiliser ou détruire ces
structures il ne fait pas de doute que
les actes commis par Wagner et la
communication macabre ou la
désinformation qui les accompagne
constitue bien des actes de terrorisme
alors c'est sûr cette résolution n'a
aucune valeur contraignante mais elles
permettra d'envoyer un message politique
un message fort pour dénoncer Wagner et
l'Etat russe qui se cachent derrière
elles ce message nous le devons aux
victimes nous le devons également à tous
ceux qui continuent de se battre chaque
jour contre la Russie en Ukraine comme
en Afrique
s'abstenir ou voter contre ce serait
choisir le camp d'un dictateur et de ce
qui accomplissent ces bases je vous
remercie
la discussion générale est close sur le
vote de l'ensemble de la proposition de
résolution je suis saisie par le groupe
renaissance d'une demande de scrutin
public le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
la parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la Commission des Affaires
étrangères mesdames et messieurs les
députés
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur monsieur le
député Benjamin Dadde permettez-moi de
réserver mes premiers mots ici pour
témoigner de notre émotion commune à
l'égard des victimes du groupe Wagner
mais aussi de notre compassion pour tous
ceux qui subissent sa présence et
surtout de notre indignation devant les
exactions et les crimes qu'il commet
chaque jour
cette indignation je la retrouve tout à
fait monsieur le député Haddad à la
lecture de votre projet de résolution
je l'ai également entendu s'exprimer
avec force mesdames et messieurs les
députés dans le cadre de vos
interventions au nom de vos différents
groupes parlementaires
cette indignation nous rassemble elle
témoigne de notre attachement commun au
respect du droit international et des
droits de l'homme qui constituent l'un
des fondements de la République
les signataires du projet de résolution
venus de nombreux bandes cette assemblée
témoignent de ce profond et sincère
attachement aux valeurs que la France en
continuer de défendre partout dans le
monde
s'agissant de Wagner le constat est
implacable que ce soit en Ukraine au
Mali en République centrafricaine au
Mozambique en Syrie au Soudan ou encore
en Libye on trouve dans son sillage les
exactions les violations des droits de
l'homme et du droit international
humanitaire la prédation et le pillage
des ressources en un mot toutes les
atteintes aux droits des populations et
la souveraineté des États mais aussi
toutes les atteintes à la dignité de la
personne humaine
les cas de l'Ukraine et du Mali sont
tout à fait représentatifs en
Ukraine Wagner est présent depuis qu'il
a participé à l'invasion de la Crimée en
2014 vous l'avez rappelé son application
au cœur de l'agression russe est
tellement centrale que même le Kremlin
qui s'est pendant un temps acharné
contre l'évidence après tendre que ce
groupe était une entité privée sans
remet désormais ouvertement mais ce prix
gaugine pour pallier les lacunes
criantes de son armée régulière
le groupe Wagner était en première ligne
en mars 2022 pendant l'occupation de
bout de chat il y a tué torturé violet
des dizaines de sépultures d'habitants
de la ville que j'ai moi-même eu la
douleur de voir lorsque je me suis
rendue porte sa marque et ce qui est
vrai pour buchal est également pour
Solidar ou encore aujourd'hui pour Dark
mode
les postures publiques de prégogi
nocives entre celle d'un bandit de grand
chemin et celle d'un pseudo ministre de
la défense mais une chose est certaine
le groupe qu'il dirige ne respecte
aucune règle aucune loi aucun des
principes du document de Montreux qui
n'a d'ailleurs pas signé document qui
vise à réguler le comportement des
sociétés militaires privées et le groupe
Wagner recrute massivement parmi les
pires criminels de Russie
l'ordre donné aux mercenaires du groupe
le 23 avril dernier de ne plus faire de
prisonniers à barmut en est un exemple
supplémentaire il s'agit là tout
simplement de la reconnaissance de
crimes de guerre une reconnaissance
froide et assumée par cela même qu'il
est commettent
au Mali nous avons tous en mémoire le
massacre de Moura en mai 2022 ou plus de
300 maliens ont été sommairement
exécutés après avoir été contraint de
creuser leur propre fosse commune et
ceci pour la simple raison qu'ils
étaient Paul
l'implication directe du groupe Wagner
dans ce crime infâme a été clairement
documenté par les Nations Unies et par
le Haut Commissariat aux Droits de
l'Homme
au Mali comme d'ailleurs en République
centrafricaine la nature des exactions
du groupe Wagner est aussi diverses
qu'effroyable
assassinat
violence sexuelle arrestation arbitraire
installation de camp de torture
mutilation
cette liste qui est de profondément la
conscience morale nous est rapporté par
les Nations Unies mais aussi par la
presse et par les organisations de la
société civile je veux d'ailleurs devant
vous leur rendre hommage mesdames et
messieurs les députés pour leur
engagement
merci pour leur engagement à ce qu'aucun
de ces crimes barbares ne demeure dans
l'ombre en dépit de tous les risques
qu'ils peuvent eux-mêmes encourir
les exactions commises par le gros
Wagner ne sont pas des actes isolés ou
des accidents de parcours ils sont le
fruit d'une doctrine qui vise instaurer
un régime de terreur et sont le bilan
quotidien d'un groupe qui pour servir
ses intérêts économiques isolent et
déstabilise les pays qui accueillent au
prix de leur souveraineté
jamais Wagner n'est parvenu par ses
interventions à rétablir la sécurité ou
à endiguer la menace terrorisme
il ne l'est d'ailleurs jamais cherché
car il ne sert rien d'autre que ses
propres intérêts ou ceux de quelques
dirigeants désireux de se maintenir à
tout prix ou pouvoir en hypothéquant
l'avenir de leur population
là où s'implante Wagner les groupes
armés progressent et la démocratie
s'étiole la République centrafricaine ou
le Mali en sont des exemples malheureux
mais je veux dire aussi devant vous que
devons ce constat notre diplomatie est
pleinement mobilisée à travers des
actions concrètes et complémentaires
premièrement nous agissons pour entraver
préventivement les déploiements du
groupe Wagner nous avons pour cela des
échanges directs francs exigeants avec
les pays qui pourraient être tentés d'y
avoir recours
cette action diplomatique menée en
étroite de concertation avec nos
partenaires internationaux vise à
alerter sur les risques induits qui sont
immenses comme on l'a vu
et c'est ainsi avant même que la gente
malienne ne fasse le choix de recourir
au groupe Wagner que nous l'avions
prévenu quand elle déploiement ne
pourrait que d'une part accentuer la
dégradation de la situation sécuritaire
en Afrique occidentale et d'autre part
mener à une aggravation de la situation
des droits de l'homme au Mali c'est tout
le sens du communiqué conjoint du 23
décembre 2021 que nous avions que signé
avec 15 de nos partenaires européens et
internationaux
deuxièmement et comme cela est injuste
le titre rappelé dans le projet de
résolution nous ne mobilisons de manière
résolue et déterminée pour ne jamais
laisser place à l'impunité lorsque des
exastions sont commises
la France soutient ainsi activement le
travail est essentiel mené par la Cour
pénale internationale en
Ukraine le bureau du procureur de la
Cour pénale internationale a ouvert une
enquête dès le 2 mars 2022 sur une
requête de 41 états parmi lesquels les
27 États membres de l'Union européenne
dont bien évidemment la France
notre soutien et la Cour Pénale
international et du reste parfaitement
concret troisième contributeur à son
budget nous avons par ailleurs versé une
contribution volontaire au bureau du
procureur en 2022 pour lui permettre de
continuer à enquêter sur toutes les
situations malgré la croissance de ces
activités
la France a également partagé avec la
cour un certain nombre d'informations
pour l'aider à documenter les crimes
commis par la Russie et par ces
supplétifs notamment à bout de chat et
met à sa disposition un magistrat et des
enquêteurs
nous avons aussi déployé deux missions
de l'Institut de Recherche criminel de
la gendarmerie nationale en Ukraine
notamment à boutcha et à izium et livré
deux laboratoires d'analyses mobiles on
appuie aux investigations ukrainiennes
le second laboratoire matériel unique
que la France est l'un des rares pays au
monde à posséder et d'ailleurs remis en
ce moment même en ce moment même aux
autorités ukrainiennes par notre
ambassadeur
enfin sous l'impulsion de la présidence
française du Conseil de l'Union
européenne le mandat de l'agent se re
juste a été renforcé il doit lui
permettre de préserver de stocker et
d'analyser des preuves de crime de
guerre de crime contre l'humanité ou de
crimes de génocide en vue de les
redistribuer aux enquêtes pénales
ouvertes par l'Ukraine mais aussi par
les différentes autorités judiciaires
des États membres de l'Union européenne
ainsi que par la Cour pénale
internationale
au Mali nous appelons de même la minusma
à mettre en œuvre son mandat en matière
de droit de l'homme pour faire en sorte
que les responsables d'exaction et
notamment ceux du massacre de Moura soit
poursuivi
troisièmement nous mettons en oeuvre des
sanctions à l'égard du groupe Wagner de
ses responsables et de ses entités
associées
parce que la prédation des ressources
naturelles est précisément le cœur de ce
modèle économique criminel les sanctions
sont au cœur de la proposition de
résolution que vous avez présenté
monsieur le député dans ce domaine nous
sommes pleinement mobilisés avec nos
partenaires européens et c'est ainsi
qu'à l'initiative de la France le groupe
Wagner a déjà été ciblé par l'Union
européenne avec 19 individus et 12
entités qui lui sont liées dans le cadre
de deux paquets de sanctions il y a plus
de deux ans et en février 2023
ces sanctions d'ores et déjà des
conséquences concrètes elles entraînent
le gel des avoirs dans l'Union
européenne mais entraîne aussi
l'interdiction de mettre des fonds et
des ressources économiques à disposition
des personnes et des entités
sanctionnées
et parmi celles-ci pour être clair
figure notamment Afghani pregojin leader
du groupe Wagner ou Dimitri hutchkine le
fondateur de ce groupe mais aussi Ivan
Maslov qui dirige sa branche au Mali ou
encore Vitali pervilliers personnages
clés de Wagner en République
centrafricaine
alors Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
si du point de vue strictement juridique
l'inscription du groupe Wagner sur la
liste des entités terroristes de l'Union
européenne au titre du régime dit PC 931
n'aurait pas d'effets supplémentaires
directs nous ne devons pas sous-estimer
l'importance symbolique d'une telle
désignation ni le caractère dissuasif
espérant lequel pourrait avoir vis-à-vis
des états aujourd'hui tenté par un
possible recours à la milice Wagner
c'est à cet homme que je tiens à saluer
la proposition de résolution soumise
aujourd'hui à votre examen dans la
lignée des initiatives prises par
plusieurs parlements dont le Parlement
européen le 23 novembre 2022
ce sujet si important si légitime mérite
que nos expertisions pleinement avec nos
partenaires européens bien sûr mais
également avec nos principaux
partenaires en matière de sanction les
États-Unis et le Royaume-Uni
car nous serons efficaces que si nous
parvenons à afficher un front uni
la désignation du groupe Wagner comme
entité terroriste n'est aujourd'hui pas
un tabou dans les éléments qui
justifient une telle décision son
nombreuses je vais donc vous assurer ici
que votre message a été entendu et je
partage très largement votre point de
vue mesdames et messieurs les députés
rien ne sera négligé pour que ce groupe
rende des comptes et qu'un terme
définitif soit mis à ses exactions
parallèlement enfin comme viens vite
votre proposition de résolution nous
étudions la possibilité de renforcer
encore les sanctions européennes contre
Wagner tout en développant des
instruments additionnels permettant de
lutter et fixer efficacement contre les
actions déstabilisatrices de ce groupe
des discussions s'engageront à Bruxelles
à cette fin monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés vous
pouvez donc compter sur notre
détermination sans faille les lignes
d'action que j'ai mentionnées tout comme
les réflexions additionnelles que nous
menons par ailleurs tout cela converge
vers un seul et même objectif
celui d'entraver avec détermination les
actions déstabilisatrices du groupe
Wagner et de l'empêcher de commettre ces
exactions dans les populations civiles
sont les premières victimes notre
mobilisation soyez en assurée et
constante et totale parce que notre
détermination est aussi forte que notre
indignation mais aussi parce que nous
sommes
tous ici farouchement attachés à ce que
la règle de droit demeure le fondement
international et celui des relations
entre les États je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la ministre
avant de mettre au bois la proposition
de résolution nous avons des
explications de votre qui ont été
demandées par les différents groupes
politiques donc je vous remercie d'être
un peu plus silencieux pour que chacun
puisse s'exprimer la parole est à
monsieur Adrien Gomy du groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègue quelques mots
avant de procéder au vote pour vous dire
au combien nous nous réjouissons au sein
du groupe Renaissance que ce consensus
quasi général puisse exister sur ce
texte autour de cette résolution
présentée et déposée par mon collègue
Benjamin Haddad que je remercie pour le
travail qu'il a réalisé plusieurs
désorateurs qui se sont exprimés l'ont
bien expliqué l'entité militaire privée
Wagner est une nuisance qu'il nous faut
combattre car depuis près de 10 ans ce
groupe a été présent dans certaines des
pires zones de conflits du globe
aggravant bien souvent la situation pour
le plus grand malheur des populations en
Syrie au Dombas en Centrafrique au Mali
ou encore au Soudan on ne compte plus
leurs atrocités les exécutions sommaires
les violences et tortures auxquelles ils
se livrent ne parlons même pas des
crimes de guerre commis par ce groupe en
Ukraine où il bombarde des villes tu des
civils et ne laisse que des charniers et
des zones de désolation derrière eux
comme abucha
dans ce contexte nous devons réagir et
il est de notre devoir madame la
ministre la bien précisé en tant
qu'humaniste et défenseur des libertés
d'appeler la France et l'Union
européenne agir à inscrire comme le
demande mon collègue le groupe Wagner
sur la liste des organisations
terroristes car il ne fait aucun doute
que leurs exactions correspondent à des
actes terroristes
comment appeler autrement des
mercenaires qui cherchent à profiter des
situations de troubles politiques en
déstabilisant les autorités en place
dans plusieurs pays africains pour
servir leur seul intérêts comment
appeler autrement des miliciens qui
effectuent des opérations d'influence et
de désinformation et alimentent le
sentiment anti français comment appeler
autrement des mercenaires qui tentent
d'assassiner des autorités politiques
élues comme le président volody
mirzelinski en Ukraine inscrire Wagner
sur la liste de l'Union européenne des
organisés des organisations
pardonnez-moi terroristes c'est non
seulement combattre son pouvoir de
nuisances mais c'est aussi envoyer un
message aux membres de groupe comme à
leur soutien ne laisseront pas la
terreur prospérer impunément merci à
vous
merci
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
Thériault du groupe les républicains
mais merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues madame le ministre il
existe un droit de la guerre il existe
un droit sous les armes
us in bello le groupe Wagner
représente un exemple
de la régression de la civilisation le
monopole de la violence légale c'est le
monopole des Etats là aujourd'hui au
cœur de l'Europe nous avons des milices
de mercenaires qui défigurent l'Europe
qui défigure l'Ukraine et je vous salue
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur et ce un groupe
de mercenaires défigure l'Afrique en
reprenant les traditions
militaromafieuses des
différents groupes de losconnais des
comptes de tiers des mercenaires de la
Renaissance ceux qui mélangent le
business et l'armée pour s'assurer un
contrôle territorial et finalement la
fortune c'était les vis Contis avec le
marbre de Carrare où c'était valenstein
avec les mines de sel du salskammergut
alors oui nous ne voulons pas revenir au
Moyen-Âge nous venons que la
civilisation continue de progresser que
l'État de droit progresse alors notre
groupe évidemment votre a cette
résolution je veux saluer le travail de
Benjamin Haddad qui a réussi à réunir
toutes les bonnes volontés autour de ce
texte et je veux ajouter j'espère que
dans cette émission il ne manquera pas
une seule voix pour le voter parce qu'en
votant ce texte nous donnerons de la
France le visage que nous avons appris à
aimer d'elle je
si la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
bourlange pour le groupe modem
le modem veut très bien évidemment
cette résolution comme je crois
l'immense majorité des membres de notre
assemblée
je voudrais
simplement ajouter au débat qui nous ont
réunis qui nous a réuni un élément qui
me paraît essentiel c'est pour signaler
l'effrayante modernité
de
la toxicité
introduite par Wagner je pense que
derrière l'entreprise Wagner nous devons
dénoncer une double tendance une double
dérive de la société internationale
actuelle la première c'est le règne de
la communication car ce qui distingue la
brutalité simple ordinaire classique
banal de la banalité de la de la
violence
wagnerienne c'est le fait que celle-ci
est mise au service d'une stratégie
d'intimidation de contraintes et
désorganisation la violence est un
instrument de communication le
terrorisme et c'est en cela que Wagner
et terroriste c'est la violence plus la
communication la seconde chose que je
veux dénoncer ici c'est une tendance
extrêmement développée pour
description de des comportements mafieux
dans la vie internationale le fait que
les acteurs mafieux deviennent des
acteurs à part entière comme la rappeler
à l'instant Jean-Louis Thériault et
mettent en cause la légitimité des états
naguèrent des tenteurs de la violence
légitime et ici on peut même se demander
bien sûr Wagner dépend des Russes dépend
du pouvoir de Monsieur Poutine mais le
pouvoir de Monsieur Poutine lui-même
n'est-il pas une dérive mafieuse de
l'état de Pierre Legrand n'est-il pas
autre chose qu'un État n'est-il pas la
prise de contrôle par des groupes
financiers véreux profondément toxiques
de cette grande nation et de ce grand
peuple de ce point de vue là en votant
pour la résolution nous signalerons et
nous dénoncerons une dérive mortelle
pour la communauté internationale
je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente
je regrette de la part de la ministre
des Affaires étrangères l'absence de
recul sur l'aveuglement de la diplomatie
française c'est ces dernières années je
trouve que cette examen de conscience
serait utile pour ne pas reproduire les
mêmes erreurs à l'égard d'autres
dictateurs que ce soit en Turquie ou en
Chine ça c'était le premier point mais
je voulais insister dessus deuxième
élément
puisque la ministre des Affaires
étrangères a nommé des oligarques
quelle sanction pour les oligarques en
France soyons concrets je pense en
particulier à Svetlana magnovic la
compagne de Timour Ivanov si ça ne vous
dit rien c'est le vice-ministre de la
Défense celui qui est et je peine à dire
les mots en charge de la reconstruction
à Mario Paul et bien on l'a vu
tranquillement faire son shopping à
Courchevel récemment et toute la famille
famille de criminels de guerre multiplie
les voyages en Europe c'est absolument
incompréhensible que malgré ses
sanctions françaises et européennes et
bien c'est famille puisse comme ça
bénéficier de voyage en Europe et de
pouvoir faire mener leurs meilleures
villes en France et donc je vous appelle
je nous appelle mais ça dépend du
gouvernement
à agir très concrètement pour soutenir
ses sanctions européennes les rendre
réels et ainsi très concrètement
soutenir l'effort pour la victoire de
l'Ukraine et puisque l'ambassadeur de
l'Ukraine est avec nous je conclus par
ces mots cela va oukrainer
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie nous allons donc
maintenant pour céder au scrutin je vais
donc mettre au voile l'ensemble de la
proposition de résolution je vous prie
de bien vouloir regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 331
exprimé 331 majorités 166 pour 331
contre 0 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
j'ai un rappel aux règlements de
Monsieur Caron
allez-y monsieur Caron
merci
merci Madame
la règlement au titre de l'article 70
alinéa 3
j'ai été gravement mis en cause
calomnier
par une collègue du groupe Renaissance
madame yadan
interrogé sur l'antenne de la chaîne de
télévision
iv4 à propos
est-ce que
c'est encore débat je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
non c'est hors débat madame c'était
c'est pas dans l'hémicycle ce n'est pas
dans l'hémicycle avant de passer au
prochain débat suspension de séance de 2
minutes je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]